If there aren't any good crap games out there, why don't you
try something other than crap once in a while? A
full-dive type VR game with over 30 million readers:
Shangri-La
Frontier A man who loved crap games and was loved by crap games
takes on a god game. Let's show him the power of a god game.  Is
n't it?
[Music]
[Applause] You can
run, you can climb, it's
wide
[Music] The
feeling of exhilaration you get when you jump into a new world
is something you can rarely get in real life.This is the
divine game, Shangri-La Frontier.When you
finally find something that seems worth it, it's
waiting for you.  Numerous monsters and powerful
rivals. Is this what it's like? Please let
me enjoy it even more. I've been enjoying this game. The
real Shangri has touched the frontier.
[Music] A
new sensation of fantasy unfolding in an open world.
Don't forget to enjoy it.  Shall we do it?
This tingling feeling of intimidation burns my skin.
I'm enjoying the game to the fullest right now.
[Applause] [
Music]
Broadcast starts on Sunday, October 1st
[Music]